all right Eric's with us in Pennsylvania
hey Eric how are you good Dave how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up well I just want to tell you about a
year ago my wife and I read on to
yearbooks and we were we were able to
pay off all our debt stash away a good
you know three-month emergency fund and
pretty much our debt-free outside of our
mortgage so it's really been great so we
thank you for that good for you make my
question is obviously with everything
going on right now it's just insanity
AMA
I have I've worked steadily for the last
20 years I've never collected before and
recently my job had had the layoffs
because of it the whole situation on my
my question is I'm looking at other jobs
non-stop and filling out applications
right now and I'm not seeing anything in
our area that is close to what I was
making so much my question is should I
not take it easier or utilize the system
but in my head I'm thinking do I do I do
that for two or three months until this
blows over and then hopefully there's
some other things that would be in a
more comparable salary range or do I
just grab what I can get and try to make
it work and that's kind of where I'm
scratching my head right now well on the
short term I mean your unemployment
check is certain there's nothing wrong
with that at all that's what
unemployment is designed for on the
short term if you go two or three months
and they're the economy is not it is not
back to work we've got bigger problems
than your income at that point shutting
down the economy and putting people in
their homes for two weeks is
astronomical for three months or two
months I don't know if we recover if
this United States recovers from that so
at some point the political rhetoric is
going to shift from the virus to the
economy and that's not a that's not to
say the viruses and a
a problem that we don't anybody be sick
or anybody to die but at some point
we're gonna have to choose between the
virus flattening of the curve and the
existence of America because it's going
to get it's going to get completely out
of hand and I don't know how much longer
these people can keep Americans in their
homes voluntarily and Americans aren't
going to they're not they're not going
to do it for a lot longer and the more
than clamped down the harder it's going
to get they're going to create a
reaction and I'm afraid it's not going
to be pretty if they don't slow down on
this stuff so anyway that that's you die
bottom line is I'm just mouthing but the
bottom line is in your situation I would
take the unemployment and whatever
employment you can find but I just don't
want you to project this out two or
three months because I honestly don't
want anybody projecting it out that far
because I under I don't understand the
medical side of it I do understand that
you cannot excite of it and it will be
you know it'll be a horrible situation
that we're all it will find ourselves in
at that point you won't be worrying
about unemployment checks by then you'll
be worrying about other things the level
of violence in the streets and the the
breakdown of government and the
breakdown of order because people are
not going to be told to stay in their
homes for very long in this country it's
just they're not going to some of you
are willing to do that but there is a
the shredding of constitutional rights
and freedom is just not going to go on a
whole lot longer you're not gonna be
able to maintain it it's just not it's
not a real it's not a real expectation
of normal humans I'm talking to way too
many people that are already so upset
about being pushed around and jacked
around over this thing and it's not that
they don't think that the virus is
serious but the the violation of
constitutional rights is
and people taking power in these
somebody's mayors acting like they have
the power of martial law is it's
honestly it's out of hand so I I mean
you can put up with it for a little
while and be civilized and say we want
we want the we certainly want everybody
to be healed and we want this virus to
be going away and we'll hold our nose
and hold our breath a little bit and let
you guys do this for a little while but
I just don't think that there's a chance
in under the Sun that any amount of
governmental interference is going to
keep people in their homes for months on
end
there's just the Americans are just not
going to do that and so I sure hope that
it's a voluntary thing on the
government's part before things start
coming unraveled that they that they
back away from the the abuse of power
that they're that they're engaging in
and it's um if you people won't behave
we're going to send you to your room
this stuff is good luck with that good
luck with that governor it's not gonna
work it's not going to work you're not
dealing with people that are you know
dealing with four-year-olds so I mean I
understand that it's a it's a good
health policy and convince people to do
it as one thing that then the other
thing so I we'll see we'll see I sure
hope it's short-lived and but you have a
people here that Liberty is in our DNA
and and that's a problem that's a
serious serious problem so I I sure hope
it just everything everybody stays calm
and and gentle and kind to each other
and generous to each other and and then
the there's a reversal of some of these
trends that are going the wrong
direction right now so good luck with
that i but yeah in a very basic tactical
thing yes I would take the unemployment
check and yes I would you know get a job
that you can get and but I wouldn't
project it out three months because the
if you project it out past three months
to return the
the coming back is not going to happen
so it's just not an option we'll have a
level of Anarchy at that point that none
of us ever anticipated we'd ever see in
our lifetimes so I hope that helps but
good luck with that